[Música]
hola qué tal estuvo un gran placer que
estamos acá todos reunidos en este
estudio 26 de radio ganada para
presentarles canadá en las américas café
nuestro programa semanal de este viernes
13 de diciembre que nos pueden ver y
escuchar en vivo y en directo por
facebook live youtube
rc y net punto sea quiere decir nuestro
sitio internet y también en nuestra
aplicación que ya después de eso le
vamos a le vamos a pedir cuentas sobre
la aplicación un cierto leonardo las
emisiones con público bueno estamos
vamos a pedir lo dejamos que eso que es
la plática venga
en vivo y en directo en carne y hueso
con este cuerpo presente de cuerpo
presente que nos pidió no en nuestro
feed de facebook que hiciéramos el
programa una vez por día
yo se lo comenté al jefe y dijo por
ahora no
entonces ya saben es la respuesta del
jefe y sin el consentimiento del jefe
pues no queda un poco complicado
bueno como ya se dieron cuenta aquí en
el estudio paloma martínez luis laborda
y leonardo gimeno bienvenida y
bienvenidos
mucho bueno bueno
y un cordial saludo a todos los que
estás del otro lado del micrófono y de
las cámaras
muchísimas gracias por esta por lo
agradable compañía y por su alta
fidelidad
sí señor
cuando uno come aquí podemos decir que
tiene seis high five porque es high
fidelity
ya está
[Risas]
y antes de demandar a este castor
cibernético a la represa roja para no
darle rienda suelta así del todo
vamos a vamos a comenzar con in solís
insólitas y efemérides solicitudes
leonardo aquí menos con respecto a las
efemérides que nos puedes decir bueno el
primero de diciembre fue el día
internacional contra el sida en la lucha
contra el sida el 2 de diciembre fue el
día internacional de la evaluación
abolición de la esclavitud
10 de diciembre el día internacional de
los derechos humanos
el 11 de diciembre en argentina el día
del tango y el día el 10 también fue el
día del retorno a la democracia en
realidad se festeja y es el día que
asuma el nuevo presidente esta semana
asumió el nuevo presidente argentina
además el intro de los derechos humanos
y eso lo acabo de decir y el 11 es el
día del tango
el día internacional del tango y después
el 18 todavía no llega la semana no lo
recuerda poco desde el día 22
entonces no podemos decir las fm como se
han dado cuenta hoy no tenemos invitados
entonces van a tener que soportar no
saben sobre solitas
y no creo que se vayan a disfrutar y no
se van a aburrir yo estoy seguro y
justamente hablando de no aburrirse luis
laborda tú tienes un dato curioso con
respecto a los billetes de 5 dólares
canadienses sí señor como vos bien sabes
paulo sí señor mucha gente utiliza los
billetes el papel moneda para expresar
sus aptitudes artísticas
[Risas]
de la calidad artística que tiene mucha
gente y vida que él se parece es poco
aunque en lo más mínimo
pero si es verdad el banco central
canadiense ha alcanzado un pedido al
público en general he tenido que
particularmente los más jóvenes
para que dejen de utilizar billetes de 5
dólares canadienses para reproducir la
imagen del señor spock para dar rienda
suelta a su arte el comandante es a su
creatividad desde la muerte de leonard
nimoy que era el artista
el actor que representaba a este
personaje de star trek se han lanzado
aparentemente en decenas y decenas a
dibujar estos billetes de cinco dólares
el banco es casi idéntica a la corona
tiene un poco la cara de nimoy no
sabemos si vino o no de otro de otro
planeta pero espero decir esto no es
nuevo
ustedes recordarán para vivo seguramente
recordarás yo lo recuerdo no sé si voy a
violar o palomas más joven muchísimo más
pero cuando cuando yo era chico por lo
menos la gente usaba muchísimo los
billetes para las famosas cadenas de
oración salgo para mensajes religiosos
de reproduzca este mensaje es 10 veces y
recibirá la bendición de lluvia
después ese tipo de cosas esto es un
poco más divertido y además con los
mails se hacían de cada momento con los
con virales en forma viral y se hacía
con lópez y escribían billete porque si
siguieran cadenas y cadenas más joven
pero la verdad que la verdad que no
[Risas]
pero esto es más moderno más divertido
tal vez y además hay que reconocer que
también tienen su carácter ecológico
porque si hablamos de que la ecología en
parte pasa por reutilizar lo que ya
hemos usado
aquí hay billetes' que ya han sido
utilizados como papel moneda y no verde
desperdicia papel la gente que hace
dibuja el billete le da una nueva
personalidad se utiliza una imagen ya
preexistente para configurar un nuevo
personaje
que se parece mucho en todos los casos
no en todos los casos hay unos billetes
están más logrados que el otro que otros
por ejemplo pero por ejemplo el banco
central de canadá dice que digo una cosa
que es puede interferir con las normas
de seguridad para eso puede ser la
seguridad es inapropiado ya que se trata
de dibujar un símbolo un símbolo perdón
de nuestro país y una fuente de orgullo
nacional
aquí cabe agregar bueno
el billete papel moneda físicamente yo
en mi billetera no tengo ni la moneda
electrónica
otra información que le quería dar a
nuestros oyentes y los que nos están
escuchando es que sí
wilfred tudor y como decía luis ahorita
fue el primer quebequense primer primer
ministro de canadá fue el séptimo
primero también bueno dibujar dibujar al
señor espín está en esta versión del
billete va a ser un poco más complicado
pero no sé o sea estamos tratando de
mostrar el nuevo porque este bueno no es
la misma foto de los cinco del billete
de cinco dólares que mostramos ahorita
pero
a menudo a propósito para que no podía
parecer bueno era la noticia insólita de
esta ocasión bueno en lo que a mí
respecta porque paloma me dijo que
quería ir de último porque la noticia de
ella es triste me dijo entonces yo les
quiero hablar de un nuevo récord
guinness que se llevó a cabo esta semana
aquí en canadá en la provincia de nueva
brunswick que tiene que ver también con
los billetes de cinco dólares de ese que
acabamos de ver y fue que se el récord
fue se alinearon 50 mil 206 billetes de
cinco dólares para eso fue este
miércoles pasado en el sudeste de nuevo
brunswick
y digamos que el objetivo de este de
esta alineación de 50 mil 206 billetes
de 925 dólares era de recaudar fondos
para un centro que se llama el centro de
recursos y de crisis familiares
beauséjour en esa región entonces era
recaudar fondos y le resultó la cosa
porque recaudaron en este evento 251 mil
dólares
para este centro y bueno la idea ahí
estamos viendo los billetes alineados se
necesitaron alrededor de unos 30
voluntarios para poder alinear todos
esos billetes de una forma muy
disciplinada creo que la línea recta es
que se controla al interior de este
récord fue que si sumamos todas esas
líneas que vimos ahí de billetes eso
suma 7 mil 435 kilómetros y 57
centímetros que llegaban desde nuevo que
está vancouver con eso
cuando comentaba el tema
y bueno era recaudar fondos para este
centro el récord anterior para terminar
empecé era un récord estadounidenses en
el estado de illinois en que había sido
establecido en el 2007 la razón por la
cual lo hicieron no nos dice la historia
y ese récord era de 3 mil 434 metros en
mil entonces más que el doble se duplicó
la el récord y bueno entonces pues me
pareció curioso mira mira la línea y
ésta me pareció curioso que se piensen
en cosas así eso es un estudio yo creo
que son zig zag no entonces van y vienen
van y vienen no tienen que estar
separados me imagino bueno hay varias
líneas no pero yo creo que todas son del
mismo el mismo número de billetes para
poder después sacar la cuenta
y los números de los billetes del mismo
número pero cabe decir aquí que 57 mil
50 mil 266 billetes de 5 dólares es un
capitalito
si hay un capitalito entonces había un
camión de transporte de dinero blindado
después para poder recoger el dinero que
ningún cómico por hay ser que conectan
las líneas pablo mira si se exhibe esa y
el billete me estaba diciendo pierre que
nos dijéramos que es una vez que la
línea llega al final ponen un billete en
el sentido horizontal y lo conectan con
la siguiente línea y así entonces si son
zig zag gracias pierna
útil útil y aparte observador nos
entendió en español que sí que está
siguiendo una vez antes cuando
comenzamos a hacer estos programas
estaba más perdido que bola de jabón en
agua honda
como decía mi abuelo
maravillosa español y además no le
cobramos nada bueno entonces ese fue mi
hecho insólito y paloma tú nos hablas
decíamos de una historia triste pero
también un poco insólita porque en
realidad fue sorprendente este miércoles
pasado el ministro quebequense de la
provincia de québec de bosques fauna y
parques pierre fould dijo en conferencia
de prensa así sin más ni más que su
gobierno era incapaz de proteger al
oscar y busque es una especie muy
querida por los canadienses que está
representado en las monedas de cinco de
veinticinco centavos y más y que era
incapaz de proteger a los caribes
menores de 50 años porque porque dijo
que los territorios de los caribú serán
muy dispersos muy variados
exactamente búsqueda de la comida de los
cuales
preocupante porque lo que quiere decir
es que [ __ ] diciendo esto justificó
también una unas medidas provisionales
que estableció el gobierno de quebec
recientemente para abolir disposiciones
de protección del caribú en ciertas
regiones de quebec y darle por otro
recurso para permitir que compañías
madereras y compañías mineras
establezcan en territorios que
originalmente son productores de
productos exactamente entonces él dijo
aceptó así abiertamente ante los
periodistas que no podía proteger a los
más jóvenes lo cual quiere decir que la
especie no está protegida porque si no
protege a los más jóvenes que son los
que se van a reproducir no sabemos si se
producen los 50 años igual de 50 años en
el reino animal son siempre es siempre
el más fuerte no el que el que domina y
a veces son los viejos los que son más
fuertes otras veces no
[Risas]
en el reino humano diferente porque yo
en principio tendría que ser el más
fuerte pero ya no me veo todavía
forcejeando con leonardo
bueno solo para concluir es que mucha
gente criticó al ministro porque le
dijeron los estudios científicos que
usted de haber leído bien los estudios
científicos que parece que no leyó según
las informaciones del diario le debo a
para poder tomar la decisión de no
proteger esas zonas porque yo ellos
creen los científicos creen que si se
les puede proteger a los caribes lo que
dice el ministro claro que sí es algo de
que debe dar una cuestión primero
monetarias que no quieren invertir y
segundo porque hablamos de territorios
que podrían servir para la extracción
minera la tala de la tala de árboles en
el juego la vida de caribú es si hay
mucho dinero juego
por ahí mensajes querido el señor nelson
contra el rincón dice buenas tardes
salud desde barranquilla colombia y
próspero año nuevo nos dice nelson
gracias
nuestro top fun javier gonzález nungaray
un saludo y abrazos para el grupo que
está en la mesa del programa saludos
dice glenda blend usca y nos pregunta en
qué emisora puede escucharla local
internacional canadá las américas en los
alrededores de montreal y
lamentablemente no en una emisora para
escuchar en su teléfono si baja la
aplicación y es un computador también su
tableta y también puede bajar el podcast
es decir que tiene la emisión en guarda
en su teléfono la escucha cuando pueda
en el momento que se lanzara la moto tal
como debe entender esa emisora de radio
no es cosa del pasado no se
desarrollaría chardy se escuchando bien
escucha viéndolos desde bogotá
así que más atrás lo dije sí saludos
amigos desde colombia más frente al
elche berria en ecuador es coqueto no es
que con los lentes
con esto de las presbicia la presbicia
que me tiene loco no veo nada así que
bueno esos son los mensajes de los
saludos que tenemos hasta el momento un
saludo a todos ellos y muchísimas
gracias por estar ahí con nosotros que
para nosotros es un gran placer poder
saber que no estamos solos
[Risas]
el castor cibernético leonardo gimeno la
aplicación que pasa las amenazas a la
gente no le damos la opción de que la
bajen pueden ir a cualquiera de los dos
centros más grandes de aplicaciones uno
para paulino para
android estos son los dos grandes en el
videíto que representa nuestra
aplicación entonces ahí pueden bajar la
aplicación en español o en cualquiera de
las lenguas de radio cara internacional
las 5
puntualmente en español van a tener la
posibilidad de ver nuestros videos los
programas en vivo y todo lo que se
produce en el seno de radio canadá
internacional del equipo latinoamericano
y también van a poder si tienen la
intención y si pueden entenderlo por
supuesto los idiomas oficiales francés
inglés e ir a buscar desde la aplicación
misma la información de las lenguas
oficiales así que vamos así que los
invitamos fuertemente a que vayan a
nuestro sitio de internet ahí tienen la
publicidad y pueden ir a bajarlo y si no
directamente en su teléfono escribir en
las tiendas escribir radio canadá
internacional en español y ahí pueden
bajar la información pertinente que
quizá pueda ser la solución para lenta
pregunta que donde esté emisora o sea no
estamos en las ondas ya como tal ahora
estamos en la
y con su teléfono celular pues si vas a
la aplicación ahí puede escuchar este
programa y ver todo lo que nosotros hace
dijo paloma el podcast también es una
opción interesante porque de esa manera
uno puede ver el contenido directamente
a su teléfono y escucharlo cuando no
pueda aunque así que cuando quieras tu
computadora
por la página internet es una aplicación
exacto pero en linux se puede hacer
navegar cómo se navega en cualquiera de
los otros y la aplicación de android no
sirve para los que tienen linux en su
computador no porque la aplicación es
para bajar a los teléfonos y en las
tablets
esperamos cosas así que los cojines
linux poder entre exacto los que pueden
los tienen linux por entra en la página
de internet y recién el punto o sea y
ahí escuchar y ver toda la información
de nuestro equipo perfecto bueno sabemos
que ese es el augusto rodríguez jarr y
anda por ahí porque ya nos mandó un
mensaje se cerró gusto no había envía
nos había enviado la semana pasada
varios vídeos y fotos que
desafortunadamente porque teníamos
invitados acá teníamos visitas en la
casa entonces nos quedó a nos quedamos
cortos de tiempo pero
vamos a poder tú tienes algo ahí la
realidad es un saludo y que me recordó
de una cosa e ismael zamora dice saludos
de salvatierra guanajuato hoy es mi
cumpleaños alcanza en el pastel dice
mientras que compramos el ticket
gusta comprar o gustavo luca dice
saludos desde la ciudad de melo
departamento de la de uruguay para mí
'la y pienso que al igual que todos
quienes escucharemos dice el programa es
una cita ineludible de los días viernes
muchas gracias para otro gustavo lucas y
quería recordarle a la gente que no lo
sabe en realidad quizás nuestros oyentes
no lo saben nosotros sí lo sabemos que
ayer fue el cumpleaños de pablo así que
estamos de festejo también no vamos a
cantar porque nuestras voces van a dar
los muchachos bonitos atrás de mí
lo que llaman eso ya los pajarillos
canto en la luna ya no se me dice hombre
[Aplausos]
yo soy del 12 y él es del 13 de
diciembre el día 13 hoy es viernes 13 y
en algunos lugares de américa es el
martes 3
mala suerte se expresa el martes 13
aunque hay una gente que tiene mala
suerte el martes 13
regresamos a césar augusto rodríguez que
nos envió un vídeo que vamos a escuchar
si pierre lo pone que es de las
manifestaciones de 4
acompañando la marcha para qué
[Música]
bocanada internacional puedan estar
atentos de lo que está pasando
estamos sentados
en el día 13 de las jornadas del paro
nacional
hay otras fotos que vamos a pasar
después cuando cuando louis presente su
tema porque justamente aborda ese aceite
donde el paro en colombia y bueno ahora
sí vamos a ver con los mensajes que
tenemos represados porque hace mucho
tiempo que no los leemos y archivados en
realidad digamos cuando comience a niños
a mente activados paloma martínez ya
primero las damas aroma amargo eso dice
para el reportaje que louis hizo esta
semana sobre canadá méxico y eeuu
rubricaron su tratado comercial javier
gonzález lugar a que nos estaba
escuchando justamente dice creo que
estos tratados entre esas tres naciones
deben ser una buena alternativa en lo
económico para ambas pero yo lo que veo
como ciudadano mexicano no lo veo
reflejado en mi modo de vivir cotidiano
quiero expresar a todos los amigos de la
redacción en español de rci mis mejores
deseos en esta navidad y año nuevo un
abrazo desde guadalajara méxico así que
gracias javier
igualmente igualmente feliz navidad
programa antes yo tengo un mensaje que
envía patricia a jankovic que se refiere
a un vídeo que circuló bastante por las
redes sociales y por los medios de
comunicación hace escasos días atrás que
fue el vídeo en el que aparecían
supuestamente boris johnson
justine crudo el presidente de francia
de manuel macro y otros dignatarios
supuestamente mofándose riéndose del
titular de la casa blanca el señor
donald trump en fin si era que había
prolongado digamos una rueda de prensa
improvisa 40 minutos creo que ese era el
motivo ya no se estaban burlando como
pero no fue contenido realmente si eso
es una burla
es una tontería muchísimas otras cosas
que merecerían burlas
él se burla de la gente
que estoy nombrada personalidad del año
por la revista times si entonces pues
también se burló de ella el bueno dijo
que es una buena niña que está mal
informada lo que es una buena goles era
según la de ellas bueno dice patricia
que el señor trump recibió de su propia
medicina y no es aceptable de ninguna
manera criticar esa que éste es para los
cargos está para los cargos que cumplen
pero vuelvo a repetir no hagas lo que no
te gusta que te hagan y todos se reciben
siete veces lo bueno y lo malo dice
sobre ese vídeo en el que pueda
se divertían un poco contra leonardo
miriam alarcón dice sobre el canal de
las américas del 22 23 y 24 de noviembre
dice este programa estuvo muy
interesante no pudo verlo en vivo de que
estuvimos de festejo familiar mi vecina
de sica soria defendió su tesis y
tuvimos un asado y se me hace bueno con
el hambre que tengo en poco tiempo voy a
pasar por la misma instancia miriam
alarcón muy bien miriam no no no va a
comer un asado lo primero va a rendir su
tesis y después va a comenzar su tesis
me gustaron los comentarios sobre el
lenguaje inclusivo me pone muy contenta
que un tucumano como luego asuma
responsabilidades tan importantes en
canadá sobre todo en tucumán
parece ser que bastante espero poder
encontrar algunos de los trabajos a los
que hicieron referencia a los invitados
cuando terminé con mi tesis claro dice
saludos a todos y nos incluye a todos
y bueno pues ya hablando justamente de
crudo un latinoamericano no digo de
trigo pero de pablo rodríguez un
latinoamericano líder del gobierno crudo
en el parlamento de canadá
eduardo dice felicidades a pablo por su
sacrificio y su inteligencia salud a
eduardo gutiérrez de méxico parece
conocerlo
no pero tú sabes que a fuerza de ver las
cosas los personajes y públicos en la
televisión un poco por todos lados
terminamos siendo digamos bastante
estando bastante cerca de ellos además
mensajes tengo acá otros sobre los
pájaros los pájaros como sobreviven los
pájaros a los fríos inviernos de canadá
inició el reportaje no soy yo bueno no
sé de qué trata este reportaje sino éste
no fue ustedes álex gómez dice gracias
por la información me hace lidiar un
poco la preocupación por mis patos
y todos los animalitos tan hermosos e
inocentes y parecen ser que sufren más y
más pero en el invierno el frío no todos
no se van y otros se quedan
la mayoría se va los chiquitos los
chiquititos se quedan los pajaritos los
gorriones aprendiendo hace tanto tiempo
es que vieron ustedes que en el verano
mucha gente acostumbra ponerle alimento
a los pájaros en sus jardines y pero se
olvida de esa tarea tan importante para
la supervivencia de esas pequeñas aves
durante el invierno
no hace mucho escuché una especialista
diciendo que hay que seguir poniendo
alimento durante el invierno porque
efectivamente muchos esos pequeños
pájaros que no ve como por ejemplo los
gorriones de los que sigo preguntándome
cómo hacen para sobrevivir el invierno
se alimentan por supuesto durante toda
la época invernal y resulta mucho más
difícil para ellos conseguir alimentos
tirado en la tierra porque ellos
tendrían que escarbar centímetros y
centímetros de nieve entonces hay que
seguir poniendo alimento en los
arriendos en los recipientes que se
utilizan habitualmente para ponerlas
el problema con eso es que las ardillas
también tienen que comer entonces se
abalanzan sobre los recipientes para los
pajaritos y arman todos desarrolla las
ardillas no hay que preocuparse comen la
basura
de mi casa el tacho de basura los cables
de emisario comen todo así que no les
pongamos comida que coman lo que no se
la ponen se las ponían los pajaritos y
las ardillas terminan festejándose la
comida los amarillos que comparte bueno
leonardo habría por ahí algún comentario
de nuestros oyentes si tenemos a la dice
gustavo lucas dice feliz cumpleaños pub
los radios han iba a ser las mañanitas
ayer 12 fueron para la virgen de
guadalupe y para pablo que no es poco es
el mismo día que la virgen de guadalupe
así que el saludo de gustavo para mi
nombre hubiera debido ser pablo
guadalupe me pusieron amador grupo
antonio gómez barrios la gracia que me
dice pierre calla del otro lado del
vidrio están deseando un feliz
cumpleaños muchísimas gracias
tenemos un tercer nombre 89 luis alberto
hay que pagar una cifra muy muy muy alta
conocer esa información desde el otro
lado del vidrio del cual les estaba
hablando se les percibe prevén nublados
y fantasmagóricos así que tenemos un
tercer nombre se demostrase los nombres
mis hice y segundo que yo tengo segundo
nombre enrique
leonardo y que ustedes deben conocer la
anécdota famosa anécdota que se ha
repetido hasta el hartazgo en gran
cantidad de ocasiones con diversas
parejas de los padres
la madre parturienta o que está a punto
de dar a luz el padre están discutiendo
en nombre de su futuro hijo o hija y
entonces definen después de largas
discusiones y meses y meses de cabildeo
deciden el nombre la madre dice al padre
qué nombre quiere ponerle al bebé y
cuando el padre llega al registro civil
anotar al bebé no se acuerda de que el
hombre no bueno eso eso parece ser que
fue lo que ocurrió en mi caso y en el
caso de algunos conocidos míos que en mi
caso no es tan trágico pero yo tengo
amigos a los que el nombre que le había
elegido la madre era realmente
deprimente entonces el padre creo que es
un gesto de justicia al cambiar el
nombre tiene el caso mío aparentemente
lo que ocurrió mi padre de respeto los
dos primeros nombres que vienen elegidos
y cuando llegó la hora de decir cuál era
el apellido dijo no hay un tercero le
agarró un ataque así de quiero que
tengan mi nombre que lo quiere no poner
su propio nombre entonces agregó ese
nombre
alberto pedro laborde efectivamente
quiero segundo apellido cual es lic
se escribe separado
de origen francés pero pueden seguir
mirando luisito o su majestad como
nacional
[Risas]
y los que nos están escuchando allá
cuáles son los segundos nombres más de
no eso hay por el segundo nombre para mí
dije no es más que suficiente yo tengo
aquí hablábamos de pablo rodríguez y
fabiana dice que orgullo para todos los
latinoamericanos en especial para los
argentinos felicitaciones y que dios
acompañe su futuro gracias entonces
comentarios luego yo tengo en realidad
otro otro comentario sobre la maternidad
es mal vista en el mercado laboral
canadiense y va a tratar de organizar un
poquito mientras luego porque hay dos o
tres frases que no les no no las puedo
conectar bien dice la información exacta
y se comenzó en 1989 1998 la mujer
además de trabajar con un sueldo
remunerado tiene
trabajar por otro que es el de ama de
casa porque siempre es ama de casa por
lo menos dice mamá en la casa y todo lo
que implica eso con una criatura o más y
el marido que por lo general y ella pone
entre comillas lo que pasaba en los 80
por ciento ochenta por ciento en la
comunidad latina supongo que debe haber
sido su caso lo que sintió ella dice que
los maridos afán que no se hacen cargo
de las tareas de la casa y con muchos
casos de maridos que se hacen cargo de
las domésticas y mi mamá hacia de las
tareas domésticas dices
se ocupa de las domésticas
pero hay muchas parejas también en las
que los roles se han invertido porque
por ejemplo es el caso de la mujer la
que tiene mejores posibilidades
laborales y es la mujer la que se va a
trabajar y el hombre se queda en la casa
haciendo las tareas domésticas no es el
caso más numeroso pero también ocurre
eso lo que sí creo es que según las
estadísticas sigue siendo más cargas de
trabajo de la casa sigue perteneciendo
lema en la mayoría de las mujeres a
pesar de todos los avances y a pesar de
que vivíamos en canadá porque en canadá
es verdad que muchos hombres hacen
muchísimas cosas que anteriormente sólo
las dolor hacían las mujeres es que la
contextura en las cocinas perdón un
neumático cuando en las cocinas de los
apartamentos las casas viejas en la
altura
del más grande mostrador de sobremesa si
era muy bajita porque de hecho ser
adjudicada esa tarea que es la que iba a
cocinar o la que iba a lavar los platos
era la mujer esto se tenía que estar más
bajita el estante que el mostrador sí
pero ahora ya lo pusieron y después dice
que en realidad cuando se trata la
planificación familiar son responsables
por igual mamá y papá y se muestran todo
lo moderno en las fotos en realidad dice
que la realidad es otra debe hablar de
las fotos del artículo con las cuales
hemos ilustrado el artículo así que ese
es el comentario de patricia jankovic
bueno y como el tiempo pasa tan rápido
entonces vamos a resaltar los temas que
hemos escogido para que nuestros escucha
veedores visiten o vayan lean oigan
saborear
y usted que pueden encontrar trabajo y
voy a comenzar contigo louis
tú nos hablas de un coloquio aquí en
montreal buena encadenó contigo porque
habíamos hablado ahorita de césar
augusto charlie rodríguez está rica vi
que había enviado algunas fotos y otro
vídeo entonces vamos a poner el otro
vídeo porque está enlazado con el tema
que tú vas a tratar y que es un coloquio
que se hace aquí encontrar en mostrar
por la paz en color y efectivamente y
sobre todo para que nos sigan en vivo y
en directo como digestivos al comienzo
de la emisión a través de facebook live
o de youtube es un coloquio que se lleva
a cabo esta tarde si quienes nos están
siguiendo están aún en el viernes 13 de
diciembre a las 17 30 horas en la ucam
en la universidad de quebec en montreal
un coloquio que realizan colombianos y
diversas y diversos sectores allegados a
la comunidad colombiana aquí para hablar
sobre las movilizaciones y protestas que
se vienen llevando de hace tiempo en
colombia en reclamo de una mejora de la
calidad de vida
condición de vida en general y un cambio
de modelo económico al actual gobierno
de iván duque esto se enmarca en un
contexto de cambio general que se viene
dando en américa latina en los últimos
tiempos con distinto signo todos
conocemos las movilizaciones que vienen
ocurriendo de hace tiempo ya en chile
del cambio de signo político que ocurrió
hace ya más de un año con la llegada de
jair bolsonaro a brasil de las recientes
elecciones ocurridas en uruguay donde la
derecha ha desalojados después de 14
años de poder al frente amplio de la
llegada o del retorno del peronismo al
poder en argentina en estos últimos tres
casos sin protestas masivas y sin
violencia en todo caso en el caso de
chile con movilizaciones que continúan
aunque hoy se habla menos continúan como
ella es calle en colombia
definitivamente pero en el caso de chile
con una impronta de violencia que no se
ha registrado al menos mayoritariamente
en colombia la persona que trabaja que
lo rescata que mayoritariamente la
protesta es pacífica aunque hay
efectivamente algunos casos
aislados de violencia y un paro general
que se está llevando a cabo que se ve
hay una foto de la persona que está en
el artículo y reclamos de diversos
sectores políticos sociales académicos
empresariales etcétera o económicos
mejor dicho para que haya un cambio de
modelo porque la sociedad colombiana
entiende que el grueso de esa sociedad
el grueso de la población no se ve
beneficiada con los beneficios que se ve
que si recibe una parte mínima de la
sociedad colombiana entrevistamos a
adriana petro hermana de gustavo petro
ex candidato a presidente de colombia y
tienen ahí el artículo muy bien entonces
recién et punto o sea en la aplicación
como el el medio que ustedes prefieran
paloma martínez tú nos hablas de la
historia de anna quien es sana y cuál es
la historia bueno ana es una chica que
nació en venezuela y tuvo que huir a
colombia es un personaje ficticio pero
es la historia de muchas otras mujeres
que han tenido que huir de algún lugar
del mundo para ir a otro lugar buscando
buscando seguridad y es una historieta
que fue promovida presentada por el
ministerio canadiense de asuntos
globales en el marco de los 16 días de
activismo contra la violencia de género
que comenzaron al principio a finales de
noviembre y terminaron el 10 de
diciembre justamente y lo interesante es
que con esta historieta cuentan una
realidad muy triste también pero que es
una realidad de la que hay que hablar
que es la violencia de género y la
violencia de las mujeres y que reciben
la que reciben las mujeres cuando salen
de sus países buscando seguridad en
otros lugares entonces ana es una chica
de 22 años que después de salir de
venezuela sufre una violación por varios
jóvenes en la frontera con colombia y
bueno poco a poco va cambiando su vida
hasta que llegando a colombia encuentra
apoyo y deja de verse como víctima y
comienza a verse como superviviente de
de un acto de violencia en su contra
entonces es interesante leer o porque
nos permite comprender un poco una
realidad sin ver las imágenes crudas
porque en realidad no se puede hacer eso
cuando cuando cuentas una historia este
tipo pero por lo menos nos permite
comprender lo que pasa en estas personas
lo que pueden pasar muchas mujeres para
estar conscientes y bueno crear una
acción probablemente personal al
respecto entonces ahí les presentamos
you una colaboración con la gente del
ministerio de asuntos mundiales de
canadá humano la historia de anna
redesigned punto sea nuevamente leonardo
gimeno tú nos hablas de las estafas con
los envíos postales o llamado también
fishing el fishing así es en realidad
siempre estuvo la lista de las estafas
que se hacen por internet pero en este
caso como el comercio 9 esto es en el
2017 supongo que ha aumentado pero nueve
de cada diez canadienses en el 2017
compraban por internet gran parte de sus
compras para las fiestas
piensa que la gente no compra mucho en
internet y realidad el comercio es
enorme entonces
se están aprovechando de esta situación
y el tema es muy fácil cuando uno va a
vive en un barrio ve que reiteradas
veces vienen paquetes a la casa de
alguna persona entonces identifiquen
hacer personas buscan el teléfono le
mandan un mensaje diciendo no podemos
desbloquear el próximo envío de la
aduana por favor me ponga sus datos aquí
y yo lo he recibido recibido y yo me
pongo a ver todos mis compromisos debo
una tablita con todas las compras que
hago cuando llegan y tal y efectivamente
no hay ningún pago de aduana y hay gente
que lo hace y hay cientos y cientos de
miles y millones de dólares gastados en
ese tema pero no solamente en el dinero
que piden para supuestamente desbloquear
sino el tema es cuando uno entra a los
datos para pagar eso los datos quedan
registrados en la base de datos de esa
gente así que están ese tipo de estafas
y todas las que hay que tener cuidado
para las compras de este fin de año muy
bien
rcn puntos sea nuevamente palomas pero
antes de presentarle lo que yo voy lo
que yo quiero que vayan a visitar le
quiero presentar a los que están en la
técnica del otro en el otro lado este
viernes se trata de benoit durante
pierde y pierde pierna gracias gracias
en total bueno lo que quiero tocar es
esta sanción
la agencia mundial antidopaje les dio a
rusia que lo suspendió durante cuatro
años por haber falsificado datos de
dopajes de acuerdo con el que no están
conformes con el informe de este abogado
de este abogado mclaren abogado
canadiense jurista que fue el que hizo
la investigación y todo eso en el
reciente puntos ya pero tenemos todavía
mensajitos en nombre completo jorge
gustavo lucas ancheta
ese nombre y eso fue todo lo que
teníamos por ahí y bueno y también eso
fue todo para nosotros aquí este viernes
13 de diciembre muchísimas gracias
y es gracias a ustedes allá por estar
con nosotros chao
[Música]